we're just a few weeks away from getting
a new Pokemon game but we've just
learned even more about sun and moon i'm
tony and this gamespot news update is in
its final form the latest trailer has
revealed the final evolutions for sun
and moon starters Rowell its final form
is desa do I a grass ghost pokemon with
the unique moves spirit shackle that
attack prevents an opponent from
switching out or fleeing battle litton
becomes in sinner or a fire dark-type
its special move is darkest lariat which
deals damage while ignoring any stat
changes finally pop Leo becomes prime
arena a water fairy type prime Marina is
the only pokemon who can use the Move
sparkling aria which quote heals the
burns of any target it strikes hopefully
all this new information helps you pick
your starter Pokemon Sun and Moon
watches on 3ds on November eighteenth
this trailer also showed off more of the
game's guardian deity Pokemon so don't
be surprised if even more of the game
gets revealed before launch to keep up
with all the biggest pokemon news you're
already in the right place
Oh